[Music]
missing the leg trying to get everything
we covered in the week it's not time for
intellectualizing go in threes
you're missing the leg you got he'll
wait going you missing the leg you're
not entering you missed the leg don't
step on the foot it has to have an entry
angle
your backs hunched get the circle you
don't have this circle miss the leg your
heel with and your back you punch good
let's go good more aggression circle
boss begin hand the in hand it's got to
go yet before it goes y'all they're
pulling it
besides go to that side that side go to
this side go you didn't drop the in hand
drop the in half Neil wait again
[Music]
them you're not coming then I have a per
turn I have a way
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
so first you go by I see this trying
right here morning okay
and that's where Sookie is that's what
my hobros okay then I wanted to make
sure if you mess it move from this so I
take this wish right right these three
parts hip arms ripped his grip and get
versa so you're in here but I'm trying
to spawn this face down so I'm gonna
loose me I'm trying to go
[Music]
so
leave they get an arm extended you don't
pull the middle to get enough on
mom do you all believe in happiness if
ascetic fool don't know madam change
okay so here's my philosophy on the
learning technique the architecture but
what you all have to capture light at
the end of the week there's nobody to
memorize any you now find employer
human fires that you do an idealized and
prescribed movement has not yet and
therefore I speak and your bouquets are
gonna have hot they F up because they
came in without the right mindset they
lost focus or fear overtook up that has
great opportunities where you start
getting glimpses of what people do when
they don't go with the program and how
you can modify your people to get back
on track you get it so you don't waste
that opportunity
secondly the only way that okay is going
to stop doing that is you have to create
a greater counter energy so that we can
does the water come get it fear has
overridden them and as you pretty
describe this I have to go in it I have
to penetrate there's fine you start
having to go it in like that because
they're trying to take out the fear of
their Hofstra you need to create a
greater energy so boom you come in now
they don't know what to do you're
helping them and you make them realize
yeah that was worse I probably should
have just gone Anna I probably should
reconcile my fear and just go in and you
helping them you also realize this
technique is not for someone who's not
pushing in and you start to feel the
other opening there's no bulk
that means it's yet
you okay
[Music]
there's no to punish 12 to 6 you have 12
to 6 12 us 12 to 6 is too close to the
vertical tops to remind that requires
way more force to get some wonderful
clusters you need the surface that
you're working with the 45-degree angle
okay so it's it's more everybody comes
in people around trying to try to think
of it almost like a pushing on you you
guys are still doing this stuff
it's not quite the perfect forward roll
anymore you get it that's telling you're
on the right track
let's go Jen you're killing me with your
mad awareness well this thing still come
around you good if they hip in there
good and find your roll
[Music]
donut pit more circular circles circles
keep your arms long good night sir go
down and come on we're not slowing down
today now you got a four people to rest
with no start over come in let's go back
now you stop just keep it going on a
circle yeah good shake your back James
and so I you have this pattern you still
have the balance you still have the
shukaku you're still in the zone the
sanctuary just hold the arm and lead
them in go everything counts see the
fear
good job rain down down good
Eddie Don Cheney that's not dog
after a second of not paying attention
oh now I'm back in go back here dog it's
a shame the whole time the whole time in
the next one all good teachers
so Billy you're in charge Super Bowl
don't let him go straight that's it
don't let him go straight sing either or
hey sensei you Dumbo straight let's back
up and do this 50 no you're not doing
the technique if you don't straighten up
shift your weight on the front leg not
50 push your knee into line with your
foot
lower your PIN low your PIN circle your
pain and stop run read that back leg
like that
I mean
you're missing the bottom triangle
you're 50/50 in your legs and as much
energy is there is on the outside of
your legs there's that much energy on
the inside of your legs it's not loose
on the inside energy is running down in
inside and outside of your legs okay and
you're not doing it so every time your
stance buckles it let's go start over
you got four to go
maybe set foot here go get your partner
timings off so your tank on is behind
that lower the table lower the pin roll
your arm roll your arm
[Music]
I call it a bedroom say you're on here
and you're about to throw we don't do
that because we use the back legs for
grounding so all you're telling me is I
then Brown I'm doing some crazy
photographs inertial roll hey our back
foot is on the ground you don't get out
like this so pull off with the dojo or
don't belong to the dojo and if you
belong to the dojo you do not runner in
this dojo
I changed partners and go go we're
working on the circle
of the two other groups there's no push
your inside legs out
holy
but thank you for sure